wir müssen dringend über ein problem
sprechen die innerdeutschen reiseverbote
regen auf und hinterlassen bei vielen
leuten fragezeichen es geht um den
herbsturlaub zum beispiel in schleswig
holstein zum beispiel in mecklenburg
vorpommern
da ist jetzt die frage wenn ich schon
gebucht habe und zum beispiel ich habe
gehört dass zum beispiel 150000 berliner
jetzt auf dem weg in den herbsturlaub
sind in mecklenburg vorpommern dass sich
eine riesige zahl bekomme ich da einfach
das geld zurück wenn ich jetzt nicht
dort übernachten kann also das ist
tatsächlich sehr sehr umstritten
und ich warte auf eine ganze reihe von
urteilen ist rau laufen bereits die
ganze menge von prozess und dann müssen
wir mal sehen wie das ausgeht also im
grunde genommen ist immer die frage wo
liegt denn das leistungs hindernis beim
reisenden oder eben beim hotelier wenn
der hotelier absagt weil er
beispielsweise gäste aus bestimmten
städten oder bundesländern nicht
aufnehmen kann oder nicht will dann
zahlt natürlich der gastwirt und dann
kriegt man alles geld zurück auch wenn
man anzahlung geleistet hat bekommt man
das zurück wenn man noch etwas zahlen
muss muss man das nicht mehr bezahlen
überhaupt kein problem
problematisch wird es dann wenn der gast
sozusagen der reisende dort ankommt und
der heute je sagt anja du kannst zwar
hier übernachten aber ich möchte
beispielsweise einen negativ test und
diesen negativ hat test hat man nicht
oder es ist im moment ja unheimlich
schwer dranzukommen denn die tests
zentren sind total überlastet und dann
meine ich dass man trotzdem eine
stornierung recht hat denn als der
vertrag geschlossen wurde
da steht ja nichts von einem corona test
in dem vertrag drin sondern steht drin
du da ist bei mir übernachten und fertig
und wenn der gastwirt jetzt auf einmal
sagt ja ich will aber erst noch das so
dass weil das eine behördliche auflage
ist dann meine ich dass man dann als
reisender die reise wieder stornieren
kann kostenlos das ist aber etwas
umstritten
tatsächlich ist es ja auch wirklich gar
nicht so einfach und wenn man einen test
hat selbst wenn man den hut ist es ja
nun auch nicht so dass der urlaub dann
ganz toll wird die reden von
zusätzlichen kosten tatsächlich auch
quarantäne ich kann also auch nicht
sofort
durch einen test belegen dass ich jetzt
entspannt urlaub machen kann also auch
diese die urlaubsfreude leidet natürlich
auch also was würden würden sie
empfehlen wenn jetzt ein hotelaufenthalt
ansteht oder auch eine ferienwohnung
gebucht ist mit dem hotelier dann
kontakt aufnehmen und vorher eine
einigung erzielen also punkt eins
natürlich unbedingt gucken wir sind
diese daten wie es die situation vor ort
gibt es da irgendwelche beschränkungen
gibt es beschränkungen für reisende aus
meinem bundesland bzw für mich denn ich
muss eben sehen aus welchem bundesland
komme ich aus welcher stadt
ist das jetzt ein risikogebiet ist das
irgendwie als problematisch eingestuft
und dann muss ich in das gebiet schauen
wohin ich will
wie ist denn dort die situation und das
ist völlig unüberschaubar
wir haben ja auch in dieser sendung
schon oft über diesen flickenteppich
gesprochen weil das ist ja im grunde
genommen alles ländersache
nachdem die länder gesagt haben wir
wollen dass alle selber regeln regeln
die das eben jetzt selber und vielfach
eben sehr unterschiedlich deshalb
unbedingt vorher mit dem hotelier
kontakt aufnehmen und einfach mal fragen
wie ist die situation kann ich anreisen
und wenn ich nur schwammige auskünfte
bekomme dann bitte unbedingt auf eine
schriftliche auskunft per e-mail
bestehen damit man auch etwas in der
hand hat jetzt mal ganz persönlich lohnt
sich aus ihrer sicht wirklich ein urlaub
wenn ich tatsächlich für einen corona
test wohl noch bezahlen muss und dann
mitunter noch einen zweiten liefern muss
macht dann urlaub wirklich noch spaß
also ich hab jetzt eigentlich auch zwei
wochen urlaub ab genau heute ab dem
heutigen montag nämlich aber ich war
nicht weg weil ich irgendwie ja auch so
ehrlich gesagt gar keinen bock darauf
habe ich glaube ich bleibe lieber zu
hause aber ansonsten der unbedingt den
urlaub fahren möchte sollte sich das
wirklich genau überlegen
und ich vermute sie haben längst
geregelt dass sie ihr geld
zurückbekommen
ich hatte vorher noch gar nicht gebucht
aber ich hätte natürlich wenn ich
gebucht hätte und das ist auch ein
wichtiger tipp immer bitte plan b auch
im kopf haben was passiert denn wenn
jetzt eben dieses krone risiko eintritt
also der absage ist risiko gebiets
absage
da sollte man unbedingt vorher schon bei
vertrags eingehung mit dem vermieter
darüber reden was machen wir denn wenn
diese situation eintritt denn was für
situation eintreten können wissen wir im
moment alle und das lesen wir auch
überall und das ist ja auch bewusst und
von daher diese situation sollte man
bitte vorher ins kalkül ziehen